luminothérapie c'est vrai que ça a été
un peu la un peu la révolution récente
dans le monde du cancer dans les de ces
dernières années
pour faire un peu schématique dans notre
dans notre corps chaque cellule est
reconnue par notre organisme et les
cellules cancéreuses elles peuvent
prendre l'apparence en quelque sorte des
cellules de l'organisme est passé outre
les systèmes de défense nos systèmes de
défense notamment notre système
immunitaire et en fait l'enjeu de ces
traitements de nouveau de cette
immunothérapie c'est d'essayer de en
quelque sorte de permettre à l'organisme
de restaurer son immunité et ainsi de
reconnaître les cellules cancéreuses
comme étant étrangère à soi-même et
ainsi les combattre d'accord alors
Florent Pagny vous avez peut-être suivi
son cas parce que c'est vrai que c'est
ça c'est de là qui est parti toute cette
histoire des immunothérapies ce que vous
pouvez nous rappeler de quoi et de quoi
il souffre et pourquoi l'immunothérapie
peut l'aider alors je connais pas
précisément le cancer de de Florent
Pagny mais enfin il en parle
suffisamment pour que chacun soit
sensibilisé mais une façon générale je
veux dire il y a pas un cancer c'est à
dire que chaque cancer est un peu
différent et même pour si on prend
l'exemple de Fallope et du cancer du
poumon chaque individu malheureusement
atteint de cancer va avoir un cancer
différent de l'autre
alors je connais comme encore une fois
de prononcer sur son cancer à proprement
parler mais on a des phases différentes
phases dire que initialement quand il a
été pris en charge en tout cas tout ce
que j'ai cru comprendre on a il avait un
traitement vraiment avisé curatrice pour
éradiquer toutes ces cellules
cancéreuses donc il a eu de recours à de
la chimiothérapie avec de la
radiothérapie et le but c'est vraiment
ça c'est la rémission la réponse le afin
de alors débarrasser de ces cellules
en Patagonie donc il a pas pu faire
dignothérapie apparemment parce que les
médecins alors l'immunothérapie c'est un
traitement généralement administré en
perfusion de 30 à 60 minutes en hôpital
de jour toutes les deux à quatre
semaines c'est ça tout à fait voilà donc
généralement c'est souvent des
protocoles toutes les trois semaines on
peut aller même jusqu'à 5 semaines
parfois alors il réputé pour être plutôt
efficace contre le cancer du poumon et
voilà et c'est vrai que
l'immunothérapie réduite moitié le
risque de rechute
alors on a montré son efficacité dans le
cancer du poumon ça a été une des
premiers enfin pas vraiment le premier
le tout premier c'était le mélanome les
cancers de la peau
on a maintenant les cancers du rein
certains cancers de la vessie les
cancers certains cancers du sein
également certaines formes pas tous mais
certaines formes du cancer du sein qui
ne dépendent pas des hormones puisque 7
quasiment deux tiers des cancers du sein
dépend des hormones mais ceux qui
dépendent pas des hormones ont
aujourd'hui aussi un bénéfice de cette
immunothérapie les formes triple
négatives
dans les cancers de la tête et du coup
les cancers de la sphère ORL également
de l’œsophage de l'estomac on avance
j'ai envie de dire par étape donc on est
en train de vivre une certaine
Révolution aujourd'hui en cancérologie
et on voit qu'on avance de plus en plus
dans ces traitements et aussi on avance
les lignes parce qu'autrefois on les
réservé à des formes avancées
récidivantes voir métastiques et de plus
en plus on est sur des formes initiales
alors après avoir lu de nombreux
articles dans les médias sont un ami de
Florent Pagny a réagi un Mado Gonzalez
qui va le programmer dans son festival
de fil certains médias aussitôt publié
des informations morbides et fausses sur
son état de santé et cela provoqué une
panique chez les gens je suis furax
parce que justement Florent va mieux je
l'ai souvent au téléphone il est revenu
à Paris il a fait son traitement à fond
il a commis une bêtise il le sait et il
a fait ce qu'il aurait dû faire Florent
ne veut pas qu'on s'arme son retour à
Paris est positif tout roule tout va
bien il pète la forme preuve que tout va
bien il fait des rendez-vous on a de
belles affaires en préparation il va pré
il va comme prévu député sa tournée des
festivals en juin oui Mathieu alors
pardon parce qu'il y a un petit peu de
ma famille c'est compliqué pourquoi
est-ce que lorsqu'on fait ce qu'on
appelle un fameux PET scan qui est un
scanner ou quand tu rentres dedans
normalement on voit tout les cellules
cancéreuses possibles si tu ressors de
là et tu n'as pas une c'est fini
ressort de là il y en a pas une et ça
revient c'est ça alors on va dire on
considère qu'il y a un phénomène aussi
de
problème aussi il y a aussi les limites
du texte du PET scanner c'est que on
arrive à détecter les cellules
cancéreuses à partir d'un certain nombre
d'une certaine d'un certain volume
typiquement pour plus qu'on parle du
poumon pour des petites tumeurs des
tumeurs qui font moins d'un centimètre
dans le poumon ça peut ne pas fixer sur
le tipster si vous voulez le test
scanner c'est comme si on avait des
flashs qui a allumé des on voit des
spots qui s'allument pour nous dire où
sont localisés et c'est le cancéreuse
et dans les plus petites tumeurs on les
voit justement ça s'allume pas c'est pas
assez puissant pour s'allumer encore des
progrès là-dessus évidemment il y a
encore des projets d'imagerie à faire et
aujourd'hui on est aussi dans les
programmes on cherche de des cellules
cancéreuses circulantes dans le sang par
exemple la prise de sang est-ce qu'on a
des cellules qui sont en transit et il y
a aussi un autre phénomènes ce qu'on
appelle les Femen des cellules souches
cancéreuses en fait si vous voulez c'est
lui qui vont être en dormance qui vont
se localiser dans un quelque part dans
l'organisme et qui vont pas être
sensibles au traitement à tous les
thérapeutiques et qui peuvent se
réveiller un jour ça peut être
5 ans 10 ans 15 ans après on sait jamais
sympa malheureusement comme ça peut ne
pas du tout revenir attention parce que
fort heureusement il y a aussi beaucoup
de cancers aujourd'hui qu'on est capable
de guérir si on peut utiliser ce terme
en tout cas et il y a beaucoup de choses
très prometteuses en sens large mais
Valérie oui vous parliez de chimiote de
chimiothérapie et d'immunothérapie c'est
forcément complémentaire ou l'une peut
remplacer l'autre ou comment ça se passe
on a le sentiment que l'immunothérapie
est moins agressive que la
chimiothérapie c'est quoi le
c'est vrai que la chimiothérapie c'était
ce qu'on les premiers traitements qu'on
qui ont été en tout cas utilisés dans le
cancer
ça détruit un peu toutes les cellules on
va dire donc ça va avoir des effets un
peu généraux au-delà de la zone qu'on va
traiter et puis bon parlait des
minothérapie mais aussi aujourd'hui des
traitements des thérapies ciblées qui
vont cibler spécifiquement certaines
voies certaines altérations moléculaires
qui vont permettre justement d'être au
plus précis dans la tumeur
pour la détruire et pour éviter
justement on va dire les dégâts entre
guillemets collatéraux c'est-à-dire les
effets secondaires qu'on peut avoir
généraux les pertes de cheveux notamment
tout ce qui est nausées diarrhée
vomissements etc bon la fatigue elle
existe elle est peut-être moins marquée
avec les traitements ciblés avec les
myothérapie mais elle existe aussi mais
par rapport à une chimiothérapie qui a
un champ beaucoup plus large en tout cas
alors par contre si je peux aussi
certaines chimiothérapies ou certains
protocoles enfin aussi grâce aux progrès
des médecines alternatives ou des soins
complémentaires qu'on propose aussi par
exemple au patients et on arrive à aussi
atténuer ces effets secondaires
c'est vrai que on essaye en tout cas de
plus en plus ça se généralise en France
et là on travaille et où je travaille
également de vraiment de mettre le
patient au centre d'un projet
thérapeutique et ne pas traiter juste
des symptômes mais vraiment dans la
globalité rappelez que la France je
crois est le premier pays en termes de
de progrès sur le cancer je crois le
meilleur pour soigner alors Cyril
évoquait l’immunothérapie comme possible
remède miracle est-ce que les avancées
justement avec l'immunothérapie ça va
peut-être faire qu'un jour on pourra
vaincre tous les cancers est-ce que
est-ce que c'est par ce prisme là qu'à
votre avis le cancer les cancers
pourront être vaincus je pense qu'il y a
plusieurs plusieurs voies d'accès
luminothérapie en fait partie
il y a certains cancers même ça peut
faire partie de certains cancers du
poumon ou d'autres organes ont
aujourd'hui on a réussi à avoir des
parler de rémission en tout cas sur des
stades très avancés qui durent durable
pendant plusieurs années on se retrouve
avec aujourd'hui avec des patients qui
ont pu parler du thème scanner qui n'ont
plus justement c'est spots qui
s'allument dire qu'on a plus de maladies
actives et c'est vrai que dans ces
situations où on a envie de enfin on y
croit donc
alors évidemment c'est peut-être pas
pour tout le monde mais en tout cas ceux
qui en bénéficient et heureusement il y
en a beaucoup et de plus en plus et ben
c'est vraiment un vrai signe d'espoir
c'est malheureusement le problème du
cancer on a l'impression d'avoir
toujours enfin le patient toujours les
pédagogues au-dessus
même 10 ans après il y a toujours cette
des pédagogues qui arrivent c'est on a
l'impression que ça revient toujours
c'est c'est en tout cas il y a certains
risques c'est pas tous les cancers mais
c'est vrai qu'on a toujours en mémoire
ceux qui malheureusement reviennent
à la fin de votre dernier propos là vous
avez parlé de l'immunothérapie en disant
que tout le monde avait peut-être pas
accès pourquoi parce que il y a une
question de coût tout le monde n'a pas
non pas du tout alors en France on a
vraiment cette chance par rapport à
l'accès aux soins et je pense que faut
vraiment que chacun se rende compte une
perfusion des minothérapies c'est
plusieurs milliers d'euros et la
solidarité fait que nationale fait que
on peut tous en bénéficier aujourd'hui
également voilà quel que soit son niveau
social quel que soit son niveau son son
on va dire lieu d'habitation on habite
dans le nord de la France à Dunkerque
jusqu'au sud à Marseille ou ailleurs
enfin je sais pas péjoratif parce que je
vais dire mais je veux dire quel que
soit le lieu où on va habiter en France
on peut avoir accès à cette
immunothérapie donc c'est vraiment une
chance que l'on a en France il faut
qu'on s'en rende compte du système de
santé tel qu'on l'a aujourd'hui de la
chance qu'on a d'avoir ce système de
santé il faut bien en prendre conscience
et enfin ça a censément qu'on a c'est
que malheureusement on a l'impression
que pas tout le monde se rencontre de ça
on parle c'est une catastrophe les
hôpitaux c'est pour ça que c'est vrai
que le système de santé en France
il est il a été mise à mal et la crise
covid a fait beaucoup de mal au système
de santé et au monde paramédical au sens
large
mais on a encore aujourd'hui la chance
d'avoir des pôles d'excellence partout
en France
quel que soit sa région quel que soit
son lieu d'habitation pour avoir accès à
vraiment toutes les séries de
traitements innovants et à toutes les
toutes les innovations thérapeutiques
alors donc aujourd'hui disent que
l'immunothérapie ça marche sur 50% des
personnes aussi ça voilà c'est vraiment
une personne sur deux qui est sensible
et qui peut être sensible à ce traité
c'est ce que dit en fait ce que je dis
quand on préambule c'est que vraiment
chaque cancer est propre à chacun et en
fait aujourd'hui par exemple on a
certains marqueurs qu'on va rechercher
sur les cellules cancéreuses qui peuvent
être en quelque sorte un peu prédictif
de la réponse au traitement